george is getting locked in here and i
can
see there's george he's
you know what i'm going to show you some
of my my uh my guys okay
okay so george brett is joining us who's
this guy who's this guy okay wait let me
see can you see him um
george toma groundskeeper
okay he's i didn't expect him to have a
bobble head okay
yeah okay who's this guy who's this guy
hold on i gotta
get it up on the screen yeah your camera
work is terrible george
okay hold on hold on okay here we go i'm
walking back i
i tried to get on my computer dan and of
course it said you need to update and
i'm not good at that stuff
okay so who's this guy right here look
at this guy
um is that um
mr kaufman no warren buffett
oh okay hey warren buffett bobblehead
i got some i got some bobble heads for
you what else do you have in there
what's the coolest piece of memorabilia
you have
the coolest piece of memorabilia i would
say would be
these three guys because i'm on my ipad
okay
these three guys right here
ooh three silver bats i like that
it's impressive and then one year one
year i went to cooperstown
yeah i was there you got inducted there
too george
yeah but then i got one day one year i
went and i got everybody that was there
baseball's signed that is impressive
so that's pretty cool yeah how many
homes
how many hall of famers do you have
there uh one
two three four eight uh
sixty four eight times eight sixty four
isn't it that's pretty good you know
what that is
yeah yeah 64. hey rumor has it that it
was 37 years ago
today that you had the uh the pine tar
home run
do you do you dread this day no
i like it so you're okay with fritzy
reaching out to you to say hey
let's reminisce about the pine tar game
when you went crazy after the home run
was taken away from you sure
[Laughter]
why wouldn't i i mean i i didn't strike
out with the bases loaded
i didn't uh have a ball go between my
legs i didn't drop a pop-up
if you're if you if you want to be known
for something
dan um hitting a home run off a hall of
fame pitcher in a big good situation
top of the ninth inning down one run or
down two runs and you get a three run
home run off
them i mean that's pretty good or a two
run home run that's pretty good thing to
be remembered for
i have a bat that i got okay
i love this show and tell here yeah i
got a bat that i gave mike botticker my
last year
former orioles and um and uh he called
me up one day and he says hey george i'd
love for you to sign this i have a bad
collection and
so the next thing you know we're talking
and he brings it over brings his son
corey with him and he shows me this bat
this bat right here is the it's the most
pine [ __ ] bat
i've ever used in my life that's a real
bat and look at that
oh my god george i can barely that is
all the the pine part about the
bat the pine tar came right to here you
know it came
it came it was two inches shorter and
they called me out on that
and then this is a bat i used in 1993 my
last year
and so mike bottica brings it over to
the house and i'm sitting there playing
with it in my office just playing with
it
and i'm going god i don't have any used
bats that i've ever used
in a game i don't have any you know i
broke
hundreds of them but you always gave
them away because memorabilia back when
i was playing wasn't that big a deal
yeah
and so and so he looked at it he says
god you loved i said mike i'd love this
mat
he said keep it keep it so what i did
what i did then is i said well i got to
give you something in return and every
year we go to cooperstown everybody
signs a bat everybody that goes there
signs a bat so i had like 55 hall of
famers on this one bat
and i got them over here in a little
thing and got about six of them
and i finally just said pick one it's
yours so he took a bet that had 60
hall of fame baseball players on it
i ever made 60 of those guys for a real
game used bat that i that i used
and the pine tar bat is in cooperstown
it's in cooperstown and the one thing i
shouldn't have done
is gaylord perry was on our team and
gaylord was a collector
he was a collector before collecting was
was was big and popular
and um and uh i get the bat back a week
later
and they sent it to me in detroit and i
go up and i use it and so before i used
it i had to clean it up
i got some alcohol and a rag and i
cleaned all the pine tar off until 18
inches i drew a little red line where 18
inches was because i didn't want to
break the rules
and uh gaylord comes up to me and he
says what bat are you using
and i said the pine tar bet he said you
know that's worth a lot of money
if you break it it's worth nothing so i
said okay and then i ended up giving it
to the hall of fame
you know your reaction all right are you
surprised
when you see your reaction when you come
out of the dugout like like
you know you're a pretty you're a
competitive guy you weren't afraid to
compete you weren't afraid to you know
throw a punch at greg nettles but you're
coming out of that dugout
have you ever been had you ever been
that mad in a baseball game before i i
don't think so no
that i when i saw my reaction i i went
you got to be kidding me i mean what's
with the flailing orange
i mean that's the craziest thing i've
ever seen in fact they did a bobble head
of that
of of the flailing arms you know instead
of a bobble head moving my arms go up
and down
but uh no i i had never seen anything
like that and then
and then when you see the full video
of joe brinkman coming behind me and
grabbing me and i don't know who it is
i didn't realize it was an umpire
because he's behind me
and so i'm trying to get away as much as
i know it could have been billy martin
or greg nettles or
goose gossage who knows and uh so i'm
trying to get away
and that really makes it look a lot
worse than it was
and then when it was
all said and done then i realized that
gaylord perry stole the bat from the
umpire
are you aware of that well that he
wanted to collect did he want
he wanted he like he didn't think
anybody was going to chase after him
so he takes the bad out of tim
mcclellan's hand
and and rumor has it he threw it to
steve ranco because
you know the police started gathering
around him and
now steve renko has it he just takes off
running to the locker room and now all
the police are following him
up to the locker room to get the back so
it makes me look like you know i was
using a concealed weapon
you know they're trying to hide the
evidence well one like it was no yeah it
was on a cork bat like albert bell
it was just yeah for a lot of guys how
how prevalent do you think were cork
bats
back when you played i don't think they
are now they were pretty prevalent when
i was playing did you ever try one
no i never did did you ever ever know of
somebody that was using them
yes some of my teammates used them
but so you put the super balls in there
so you you drill out the
center or the top of the drill out the
center of the bat down to about five
down about five inches from what i'm
told and then they get
cork and they stick cork in there and
just cram that cork in there as tight as
they can or super balls or whatever
and then they put some putty over the
end of it so you can
can't really tell and then again i think
it was greg nettles
uh one time uh swung and the top came
off in super balls when flying all over
the field
you know and then you remember chris
sabo disable when he broke a bat and two
yeah um how the the hole inside of the
bat was hollowed out and it was cork
inside
now i don't know if they use a cabernet
a merlot
you know a good chardonnay or what i i
don't know what wine
goes best with that but uh yeah there
was a lot of that cheating going on
he's uh george brett he uh is uh the
royals vice president of baseball
operations the former royals third
baseman
you hit what 317 home runs something
like that
in your career if you if you played now
launch angle the whole thing uh
i don't would you have 3 000 hits or
would you have
450 home runs i would have 3 000 hits
i think i don't my my deal is to be
honest with you dan i
i don't think you create launch angle
if you're bat my bat stayed through the
zone in a long time
the same plane as the ball came my bat
stayed on that plane a real long time
so that's one reason i didn't strike out
much uh
if i hit the ball on the square on the
dead round part of the bat right square
it's going to be a line drive if i hit a
little below that it's going to be a
ground ball
if i hit a little above that it's going
to create the launch angle but i think
now people are trying to create launch
angle
that's why you have so many strikeouts
in the game and i think that's why the
game's getting a little more boring to
watch
because there's too many strikeouts and
and the ball's not put in play as much
uh
to me to me launch angle is the angle of
the ball comes off the back i don't
think you can create it
but i think a lot of people are teaching
that now and as a result
i mean i wouldn't have changed
never tried well i tried to hit a home
run i never i never hit one trying
so i learned really early in my career
don't try to hit home runs home runs
come as a result of a good swing
and i just tried to take a good swing at
everything and tried to hit a hard line
drive up the middle or right center or
left center
if i got it pretty good it would it
would if i got a little
higher on the bat it would be a fly ball
and if i hit it good enough it'd be a
home run and
playing in the biggest ballpark in the
american league
in kansas city uh 81 home games
and and astro turf field i mean it was a
very fast field
our teams never really did hit a lot of
home runs we were singles doubles
triples teams and stole a lot of bases
um and that's what our our recipe for
success was and we were a really
successful franchise while when we did
that
it's great to talk to you hope you're
well and yeah i'm doing good how are you
holding up
everything's good uh yeah no complaint
yeah we we just been uh
kind of quiet here trying to be smart
and uh just trying to be a five-tool
broadcaster here
yeah well you've always been that thank
you george thank you i appreciate that
as always
and uh sorry i didn't call you on our
birthday yeah but you kind of missed
that the last few years
yeah i know i was hoping you'd call me
i don't know how to get a hold of you
you know how to get a hold of me
fritzy you can give george my number
finally sure
yeah all right yeah i mean i i know chad
ward has it
oh chad ward our traeger barbecue guy
yes he does
george isn't he the best oh man i love
that guy
i i text him last night because i'm
making something for the family today
and and he got back to me you know in
the span of like 15 minutes with the
recipe
of what i need to do on the traeger
grill today he always does that to me if
i ever have a question if i'm going to
try something new i text him i said okay
how do i do this
and and within 10 minutes he usually
responds
he called me the other day he uh uh what
do they call that not a zoom call uh
facetime yeah facetime me from ken
griffey's office
[Laughter]
saying i thought your office was pretty
cool look at this
and so then i had to show my world
series trophy and
some silver sluggers and i showed him my
mission hills country club
uh trophy for being the club champion
two years ago
which is the biggest upset and the
biggest farce
in the history of anything but uh i
showed him that and i says yeah but does
ken griffey have any of these he had all
his silver sluggers
he had 20 gold gloves lined up i got one
i got three silver bats i don't think
ken grocery ever won a batting
championship though but it was kind of
cool
comparing offices with him in florida
but uh
now dan is or chad is one of the
greatest guys i've
ever met in my life yeah and he cooks
for you a lot doesn't he yeah
yeah he shows up at the super bowl
anytime we need him
chad shows up he's really a generous
soul
well you know what you that you should
think about doing is going to salt lake
city the headquarters for traeger
yeah and they have and he does cooking
classes
and me and my son jackson who's a big
tailgater for all the chiefs games
uh he'll have 50 people at his at his uh
tailgates
charges everybody 20 bucks and he'll be
doing brisket the day before he'll be
doing ribs
and if it's a noon game they leave at 6
30 in the morning to go set up their
thing they even have a urinal there
uh in a tent with kitty litter in there
and
but it's it's pretty cool and he's he's
just become a great great great friend
yeah i love him he's a good i love the
traeger
i just love the trailer well it's good
to connect with you buddy
and uh thank you be well and uh i'll let
fritzy
give you my number george okay sounds
good all right now where are you at
where are you at you're up connecticut
uh
connecticut okay if i ever get up there
i'll look you up we'll play golf or
something
that would be nice or we'll just have uh
you know barbecue
sounds good thank you george that's uh
the great george brett it's
37 years ago today the pine tar game